between 7th of january and the 19th
february
stratford-university council is
consorting on some new planning guidance
this is called the gypsy in trouble and
travelling show people supplementary
planning document
this short video explains what's in the
draft guidance and how you can give us
your views during the consultation
everyone should have the opportunity to
live in a good quality home
and the local planning system has an
important role to play
in ensuring fair and equal treatment for
gypsies and travelers and traveling and
show people
by enabling the provision of suitable
accommodation
just to set the local context the
council's main planning policy relating
to gypsies and travellers
is policy ces 21 of the course strategy
and this was adopted in 2016.
this supplementary planning document
will once adopted provide additional
guidance on the implementation of this
main course strategy policy
so the draft guidance covers three main
elements
firstly sets out the accommodation needs
for gypsies and travellers within the
district
secondly it provides guidance on the
broad locations across the district that
may be suitable for new permanent sites
and thirdly it identifies some design
principles on the layout and size of new
pictures and sites
i'll now briefly run through each of
these three sections in turn
so what is the accommodation need within
stratford or navy districts
well to work out how much additional
accommodation we need an assessment was
undertaken
in 2019 this is called a gypsy and
traveler accommodation assessment
and you can view a copy on our website
the study identified that by the year
2035 we need between 59 and 70
additional permanent gypsy and traveller
pitches and six
additional travelling show people plots
it is recommended that this additional
accommodation be met in two ways
firstly by the provision of new
permanent sites and secondly by the
intensification
and or extension of existing sites
i should note that this spd does not
allocate specific land for new sites
as this can only be done through a
higher level development plan document
which would be subject to independent
examination
the council has started work on this
high-level plan for gypsies and
travelers and travelling show people
and we are currently exploring options
to identify new permanent sites
the second aspect of the guidance
identifies areas within the district
that are more suitable for new permanent
sites
the map included within the spd which
you can see here
builds on the broad locations for new
sites that were identified in the core
strategy
and clarifies the areas within the
district where the council would be
particularly supportive of the principle
of new sites
on the map this is the areas not shaded
red
it includes areas that are not
identified as having significant
environmental
or historic importance such as the green
belt
conservation areas or the cotswold area
of outstanding natural beauty
and also areas that are in sustainable
locations
by sustainable locations we meet areas
that are either within three miles of
the towns and larger villages
or within two miles of the local service
villages which are some of the smaller
villages
that have a primary school it is hoped
that this map will provide some
certainty to both
applicants and local communities and
will encourage landowners to bring
forward sites to help meet the
district's needs
any planning applications will continue
to be assessed on a case-by-case basis
in accordance with national and local
planning policies and any other relevant
material considerations
moving on to the final aspect of the spd
which relates to the design of new sites
and pictures
a range of design criteria are set out
and will apply to all schemes seeking to
gain planning permission
whether this is an additional picture on
an existing site or a completely
new site however as all sites will have
different characteristics the guidance
will
be applied with a degree of flexibility
so that's it for the overview of the
draft guidance i hope that this short
video has been helpful to you
you can find out more and make your
comments by visiting our website at
www.stratford.gov dot uk
forward slash gmt hyphen spd
the public consultation runs until the
19th of february
and we look forward to hearing your
views once the consultation has closed
we will consider all of the comments
received
and make any necessary changes before
the guidance is adopted by the council
later this year if you have any queries
on the consultation
please email us at planning.policy at
stratford.hyphen.gov.edu
or call us on oh one seven eight nine
two six zero
three three four thanks for listening